before we start oscar nominations are
officially
out and if you're behind on your viewing
don't worry
we've got entertainment tonight's kevin
frazier stopping by on friday
to tell us exactly what we need to watch
yes they're all out there
oscar season's my favorite season of the
year so can't wait for that but first
today we're doing the news
declutter style and listen to this crazy
statistic
it's estimated that americans have have
43 billion dollars of
old gadgets just sitting around the
house and i you know
i'm talking to you because you got a
flip phone and a ziploc bag at a drawer
somewhere
drew you had remotes in your junk drawer
uh so i know you know what i'm talking
about and usa today reports now you can
get
money for those items on the declutter
app and website
so unlike sites like ebay where you need
to upload photos and descriptions of
your old stuff
this is so much easier because you're
selling to one company here's how it
works you sign up on their site
you submit basic information on your
items what condition they're in
old computers old phones they're going
to give you an offer
money and if you accept the offer they
take care of the shipping
they're going to buy your old
electronics i have like five storage
units do you think they would take that
i totally would i would think about that
so i try to
i try to pay my devices forward like
when i get a new phone or something i'll
give my own to my brother or wipe it
clean
but i and i know i'm not alone i
certainly have a drawer of like two old
computers i have to get rid of
yeah yeah and this is a way maybe we
could make a a doll or something
i have to say i am doing a deep dive on
this declutter app because we all need
this app it blew me away um next we're
talking about
after dinner cleanup sometimes it's a
real slog because you've already done
the delicious part which is
and then you just want to like sit in
the juices of laziness
and like you know digestion
but apartment therapy reports that the
pizza
roulette cut and surfboard is here to
help
check this out it turns clean up into a
little game
you serve your pizza on here and as
each person takes a slice guess what
they reveal what their
post pizza chore is and just like that
the pizza board has spoken i love this
so much because whenever i'm eating all
i'm thinking about it's like oh i got to
do the dishes i got to do that now it's
like
you get assigned a chore i would like
one of these slices to say ross you must
walk around the block eight times
stop eating pizza put it down all right
i'm gonna take a piece of pizza and then
mine says have another slice oh man
you won the pizza slice lottery can i
just take a slice to see what my chore
would be
yup she doesn't like that oh my
oh
okay and i mentioned that beautiful the
new company i have is making a pizza
cutter
isn't this cool that's a gorgeous pizza
cutter i made it you really did
yeah um can i take a piece piece did you
see what my chore would be
um if you dare i'm not gonna try it i
just it says
trade your chore okay so so far drew and
i don't have to do anything
i know we just have to eat more and like
delegate i got the trash take out the
trash okay there you go
turns out that pizza's trash we're
taking it out
uh i don't know what i i i if a sponge
and like a jar of old tomato sauce had a
baby
there it is this is the first time i
haven't wanted pizza well the wheel's a
winner everybody
the wheel is good yeah lose the pizza